when i go to these like china nights who
do you see there what are china nights
well we're asian you know because you
know the um
like the laugh factory has on friday
nights they have laugh out loud or china
china
well i don't know what it's called but
it's they always have diversity you know
how like
asian porn has the most racist
titles
yeah
they like you know i know the world
has grown
to be very sensitive about slurs
and what we took but
no one gave the memo to the porn
industry oh no because it's like if you
go and see asian porn it's like
[ __ ] fantasy [ __ ] holes number six
right ching chong you know yellow [ __ ]
yeah
i'm telling you right now that's a
bangkok stick nine [ __ ] that's true oh
i like that yeah yeah that's the next
special yeah or something
it's always like some sort of gonna say
that was my nickname
have you read those things those like
that those like asian they're aggressive
right and then sometimes like when you
they say you know let me look them up
yeah
um singapore slanted you know
[ __ ]
but then when they do an interview in
the video they're like girls that grew
up in riverside
like hi um my name is sammy
right you're like that's not no [ __ ]
goo goo from slang i from singapore
this is false advertising yeah oh dude
there's one top 25 best-selling asian
porn movies of all time let's go shout
out to asakira insatiable number one asa
okay uh walk on the wild side okay all
right okay all right all right stop stop
stop stop stop there let's start let's
address that okay thoughts captain my
thoughts are this all right
if you right were in your sh you wrote a
movie called walk on the wild side all
right and you're in a you're at fox and
you're pitching it to whatever they're
filming
person is right yeah they'll walk you
right out of the room friends they'll
walk you out yeah they'll walk you yeah
okay walk you right out of the room man
give me another one uh this is pretty
easy caucasian that's easy go ahead
that's not that offensive uh
miso horny yeah there we go that's what
i'm saying it's like that's [ __ ]
[ __ ]
persuasion one okay that's the thing
what's the most racist one that you when
you react honestly i think it was a walk
in the wild it is because everything
else was like
j-jugs oh japanese jugs okay uh-huh yeah
j-jugs 40 little asians little asians 40
little asians what is that even
it's yeah what's that what's that thing
how do you say it when
when it's redundant what's there's a
term for that
webster um redundant redundant's the
word i think
why did you think because i looked over
at my peripheral that was a good trick
because you made us all go thank you
that's a trick me off me love you long
time yeah it's like all those ones you
know you couldn't you couldn't
you know
name a chinese restaurant called me love
you a long time i don't think
could you no i but i think that the fall
places um they get away with in the
early
and 2000s they try to get creative like
the you know the
you you like what like what the [ __ ]
like what the [ __ ] [ __ ] i saw a thai
place called titanic
that's actually pretty good that's
clever
that's clever if you had a restaurant
what would you name it
it had to be a pun well i mean the
honest truth would be um i like
restaurants where there's no sign
me too like i like restaurants where
you don't even know it's a restaurant
right so if i were gonna do a restaurant
there would be no sign
probably a symbol
some sort of like small
symbol
you know maybe an asian symbol oh yeah
or something
and then um it would just be reservation
only
okay
and it would be so pure i think you'd
really enjoy my restaurant
i would get like
mashed potatoes pop popsicles
oh popsicles
yeah
how's what a popsicle that tasted like
thanksgiving food
i'm down